وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنها لا تزال لا تعرف شيئًا
عن حالة الأمريكيين الذين
يُعتقد أنهم محتجزون كرهائن لدى حماس،
وبينما لا يزال مكان وجودهم
مجهولًا، يعتقد البعض أنه يمكن
احتجازهم في أنفاق غزة، وقد مشى ضيفي التالي
بالفعل عبر تلك
الأنفاق التي أريدها  أحضروا
مراسلة الشؤون الخارجية المخضرمة رينا نان
رينا، هذه الأنفاق هي نوع من
مصدر بعض الغموض أه ولكن
يُعتقد أنها تقع حرفيًا تحت
أقدام الشعب الفلسطيني كما
ترون هنا تحت المباني
أسفل الشقق
لديك أيضًا بعض مقاطع الفيديو النادرة إلى حد ما،
وهي من عام 2017، هل يمكنك إطلاعنا على
ما ننظر إليه هنا وما الذي
مررت به كما تعلم، يجب أن
أخبرك أن هذه الأنفاق أكثر
تفصيلاً بكثير من تلك التي ذهبت إليها
وتلك التي مررت بها  تم بناؤها من قبل
مراهقين وهي في الأساس مصنوعة من
التراب ومن المحتمل أنها تستخدم لمرة واحدة ولكن
يمكنك رؤية احتمال
وجود الرهائن في هذه الأنفاق المحصنة هنا
بالخرسانة أه ما يثير
القلق أيضًا هو أمر لا يصدق مثل أجهزة
مكافحة الكشف الإسرائيلية  الأنظمة الخاصة بهذه
الأنفاق التي لديهم، من الصعب حقًا أن تصبح
حماس أكثر ذكاءً على
مر السنين فيما يتعلق بقدرتها على الدخول
وتدمير هذه الأنفاق، لذا ترون مدى
تحصينها وحقيقة
أنهم يستطيعون النزول إلى هنا والذهاب
لم يتم اكتشافها، سأعرض بعض
الصور الإضافية هنا وترون
الأوساخ هنا، تلك التي مررت بها
كانت في الأساس عمري 54 عامًا، وكنت قادرًا
على السير في كامل مسار
هذه الأنفاق ثم ببطء  لقد بدأت
في الكهف، وقد تم
تصميمها وتشييدها بشكل أفضل بكثير لأن
الأنفاق التي من المحتمل أن يكون هؤلاء الرهائن هم الذين
أراهن أنها من المحتمل أن تكون
غير مخصصة للاستخدام لمرة واحدة،
بل مخصصة لهذا النوع من الحروب الحربية، بينما القصة الأخرى هنا تدور حول
المدنيون الذين يُطلب منهم الآن
إجلاؤهم أه نحن ننظر هنا إلى
خريطة الإخلاء هذه، هناك
مكان واحد فقط يمكنهم الخروج منه
وسيكون هنا تمامًا، هذا هو
معبر رفح الذي يؤدي مباشرة إلى مصر أه
أنا ذاهب  لإظهار نوع آخر من الصور
هنا، هذا هو ما تبدو عليه الصورة عن قرب،
ما هي التحديات هنا التي يواجهها
المدنيون الذين يحاولون الخروج بشكل جيد،
إنه أمر لا يمكن التنبؤ به بشكل لا يصدق وخطير
بشكل لا يصدق، نحن نعلم أنه
كانت هناك غارات جوية إسرائيلية، لذا
فأنت باستمرار تفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف ما يمكن أن
يحدث في هذه المنطقة، فقد قالت وزارة الخارجية
أيضًا أنه إذا تم فتح معبر رفا
في النهاية، فما يمكن أن يحدث هو أنه
لن يتم فتحه
لفترة طويلة من الوقت، فسوف يُفتح بسرعة ومن
المحتمل أن يُغلق، لذلك أنت"  لدينا
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص هنا في قطاع غزة
يتطلعون إلى الخروج، وهذه هي نقطة الخروج الوحيدة
الآن وهي رافا التي
تدخل إلى شبه جزيرة سيناء المصرية
هناك، لذا لا يمكن التنبؤ بالأمر
الخطير وأيضًا حقيقة
أننا سمعنا ذلك  لا نعرف كم من الوقت
يمكن أن تظل مفتوحة وبالطبع هذه
مسافة مهمة جدًا هنا إنها
صغيرة إنها مساحة صغيرة ولكنها
مسافة كبيرة إذا لم يكن لديك
الكثير من الوسائل للوصول إليها إذا لم يكن لديك  لديك
الكثير من الوسائل وأيضًا لا تعرف
المدة التي ستستغرقها في التخييم هناك، لذا فإن
حقيقة أن هؤلاء الأشخاص قد يكونون
هناك يحاولون الحصول على المساعدات الإنسانية، فإن
المصريين أيضًا لا يريدون استيعاب أكثر من مليون
شخص في مصر  لذا، فهذا مصدر
قلق كبير بينما قالوا إنهم
سيسمحون للأشخاص متعددي الجنسيات بالدخول
إلى مصر شهريًا والمغادرة عبر القاهرة، هؤلاء
الفلسطينيون القادمون عبر القاهرة ليس لديهم هذا
الخيار، حسنًا، رينا نان، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك